on a un problème vous savez c'est une
obligation légale en fait elle à la
police tu retourneras cadavre sur les
bras
bah c'est qu'elle l'a placé en congé on
n'a qu'à la mettre là dedans en
attendant regarde vite chez les juste là
elle est juste là sur les enjeux les
croisettes à la avec un énorme stock
dans la bouche il ya derrière malheureux
non mais sérieux vous pensé que j'allais
comprendre là avec vous vous symbole à
la con là haut
[Musique]
en principe si vous avez su trouver le
chemin jusqu'à cette vidéo youtube c'est
que vous avez moins de 45 ans et que
vous avez entendu parler de smiley de
frimousse en bon français la commission
d'enrichissement de la langue française
recommande le terme frimousse et
l'office québécois de la langue
française le terme binette voilà dans un
message association facétieux que
quelques caractères typographiques qui
évoque un visage expressif et c'est quoi
un smiley du coup hein parce que voilà
n'est pas plus avancé à l'origine ce
terme désigne l'association de lettres
ou de symboles visant à dessiner un
sourire comme le traditionnel deux
points tiré parenthèse fermée mais son
usage s'est étendue aux différents
moyens de communiquer des émotions en
détournant lusage des caractères de
votre clavier
aujourd'hui on peut constater que ce
terme s'est étendu pour se confondre
alors avec celui d'émoticônes qui était
celui qui était consacrée pour cette
définition plus large à savoir que le
terme et mogi est un emprunt au japonais
strictement synonyme au terme émoticônes
donc pour résumer le smile est à
l'origine le nom de l'émoticône qui
illustre un sourire mais aujourd'hui ce
terme est souvent utilisé pour désigner
tout type d'émoticônes à base de visages
qui sonnait tout type d'émoticônes tout
court alors ça n'aura échappé à personne
nous a juste my lai s'est surtout imposé
avec internet et la téléphonie mobile
donc fin des années 90 début des années
2000 c'est alors surtout associé aux sms
à la base donc au langage sms que l'on a
fustigé pour tout comme vous le savez
sûrement et je vous rassure à utiliser
des abréviations ou des petites têtes
marrante ne rend ni débile ni les traits
c'est pas le sujet ici donc je vais pas
épiloguer
mais non le langage sms ne signe ni la
fin de notre belle civilisation
française ni une rupture dans l'histoire
de la maîtrise du code écrit ou voilà ça
c'est dit le smiley exploite bon qu'à
l'origine les caractères disponibles sur
un clavier de téléphone et si ce sont
les smileys history qui reste en vogue
leur usage s'est diversifiée avec le
temps d'ailleurs vous l'ignoriez
peut-être mais il existe deux grandes
familles de ce mail
les occidentaux et les orientaux et
premier étant à 90 de griffe au crédit
sur la bouche et se compteront
historiquement en europe et le second
étant
horizontaux il focaliser sur les yeux
c'est ce qu'on trouve historiquement au
japon et que l'on nomme chaos mochis
deux points tiré parenthèse ouverte
équivaut alors à parenthèse chapeau tiré
dix huit chapeau parenthèse deux points
apostrophe parenthèse fermée équivaut à
t majuscule tiré 18 t majuscule
bon j'ai pas faire toute la liste non
plus surtout que tous n'ont pas
d'équivalent si vous vous demandez
comment ça se passe ailleurs dans le
monde
sachez en tout cas qu'en corée du sud et
en chine qui ont chacun un système
d'écriture propres le système
horizontale domine aussi la plus grande
diversité et la plus grande expressivité
se trouve certainement dans ce type qui
aujourd'hui exploite parfois au maximum
la diversité des caractères informatique
mêlant plusieurs systèmes d'écriture
celui ci par exemple exploit que le
chiffre 9 arabe la parenthèse ouverte la
ponctuation taille le symbole politique
de la brève renversé souscrite notant à
son nom syllabique le symbole politique
de ligatures tyrant souscrit une
parenthèse fermée et le chiffres arabes
aux perses 6 c'est pas simple c'est pas
simple les smileys ont participé au
renouvellement de la manière de
communiquer en bouleversant la frontière
entre l'oral et l'écrit ils se sont
particulièrement bien imposé sur
internet que jacques à nice définit
comme l'endroit du par les cris
l'endroit où le registre du parler et de
l'écrit ce son mélange
mais pourquoi donc mais comment donc me
direz vous avec l'arrivée des moyens de
communication écrit synchrone
c'est-à-dire de conversation en direct
par le texte finalement comme msn icq
irc skype ou les chatrooms de skyrock
parce que oui je suis aussi vieux que ça
as v 28 hommes torse nu dans 52 il
demeure toujours que l'on ne parle pas
comme l'ont écrit on a développé un code
spécifique aux par l'écrit justement on
a plaqué de l'oral sur du texte des
interactions spontanée sur un mode
d'expression qui en principe ne le
demandez pas jusque là
le smiley alors est utile puisqu'il
occupe de fonction il permet d'éviter
les malaises et les malentendus en
associant une émotion un message afin de
préciser l'intention avec lequel il est
formulé et il permet également de
relancer ou pour suivre une conversation
parce qu'ils véhiculent une émotion
l'usagé cela est d'autant plus important
entre deux personnes si elles sont
proches ils sont particulièrement
bienvenues pour dédramatiser ou facilité
la conversation autour des sujets graves
ou difficile mais si les smileys vienne
lever des doutes sur nos intentions
lorsqu'on communique à l'écrit ils
peuvent également ancré
c'est que les màj ça peut être super
intéressant parce que au tribunal
comment tu interprètes par exemple un
pistolet quand on voit quelqu'un
et bah tu vas y avait en france un gars
qui avait envoyé un pistolet à son ex
copine où il avait aussi fait des
menaces de mort et tout ça et on a
reconnu que le pistolet en lui même mais
c'était aussi une preuve qui avait bien
une menace de mort sa mère
oui quand même c'est vachement
intéressant après en france on n'a pas
trop trop de cas c'est surtout aux états
unis où ça commence à se développer mais
je pense qu'en france on arrivera tôt ou
tard à la même décision
tu as je me demande si par exemple si tu
envoies at-on salariés tout le temps une
meuf dans va tout le temps les pêches et
les aubergines et tout ça bon ben on
sait que c'est un peu connoté quand même
est ce que ça pourrait être considéré
comme du harcèlement sexuel bas à la
question elle se pose tu vois ça
pourrait être intéressant de reconnaître
justement 20 que ça peut être une preuve
en elle même après si on envoie juste
les mots dits pêche et aubergines je
sais pas ça suffira mais on va utiliser
les emoji pour accréditer la thèse qu'on
défend ballu harcèlement sexuel ouais
donc le contexte important si jamais
jean bourgeault ajuste une tête de mort
ou la tête d'un mec mort pas suffisant
bah ça va être un peu compliqué parce
que on pourrait dire tard ip par exemple
et que tu pensais pas alors si tu as
envoyé des messages avant qui était un
peu menaçants et qu'ensuite plus tard
temps va juste une tête de mort la wii
donc le contexte je pense qu'il est
vraiment important
limoges il va soutenir en fait la task
et qui a tenu coi d'accord parce qu'on
considère qu'il apporte une information
subjective en plus bas ça dépendra du
juge mais ouais moi ça me semble pas
déconner ok
non mais ça intéressant les trucs de
droit des fois en augmentant le nombre
et la variété des smileys la question de
leur traduction se pose alors de plus en
plus
vient-il communiqué une émotion
remplace-t-il un mot se substitue t-il à
une phrase cette simple question trahi
le véritable rôle du smiley ils sont
probablement à l'écrit ce que sont les
interjections à l'oral et c'est quoi une
interjection me direz vous et bien je
vous répondrais mes amis c'est les mots
dont on ne sait pas trop quoi faire et
que l'on dénigre un peu trop souvent
trop vite
vous connaissez peut être les noms les
adjectifs les adverbes et les verts d'un
côté et les prépositions les
conjonctions les articles et les pronoms
de l'autre c'est ce qu'on appelle des
classes grammaticales celles qui sont à
gauche sont dites lexical
c'est le mot qui désigne des trucs dans
la vraie vie et celles qui sont à droite
sont dites grammaticale c'est les mots
ou ti dont on a besoin pour faire des
phrases qui ont du sens
il se trouve qu'en réalité il existe une
autre classe de bep une classe oublier
qu'ils ont tant est resté in étudiée par
la linguistique
cette classe vous l'avez deviné c'est
celle des interjections les
interjections sont des mots ou groupes
de moins variable qui fonctionne
indépendamment et dont le rôle primaire
est purement émotionnel elle sont
universelles présente dans toutes les
langues du monde et elle possède un rôle
communicatif très important à l'oral et
son que vous émettez quand vous hésité
quand vous riez
quand vous être surpris quand vous vous
cognez par tout ça ce sont des
interjections les interjections primaire
même pour être précis les interjections
secondaire c'est quand vous plaquer des
mots sur ses émotions comme [ __ ] ou
bordel de merde à l'oral même si vous ne
faites pas attention elles sont
prédominantes et apporte du contexte à
votre propos des informations à la bonne
compréhension de votre message tout
comme les smileys les interjections ne
sont pas présentes à l'écrit ou alors
très rarement même dans les
retranscriptions d'interviews qui sont
pourtant des échanges l'euro par nature
tout interjections sera gommée sauf
lorsqu'il s'agira éventuellement insisté
sur le côté populaire de la personne
interviewée ce n'est en tout cas jamais
pour servir son propos c'est uniquement
pour dire quelque chose de sa
personnalité
vous voulez montrer la lure timides ou
hésitants de votre interlocuteur vous
transcrire et quelques oeufs suivi de
trois petits points
si au contraire vous voulez le montrer
comme confiant et sûr de lui vous vous
abstenez de manière générale les
interjections sont chassés lorsqu'il
s'agit de bien écrire ou d'écrire
sérieusement vous ne verrez jamais de
aaa dans un texte de littérature ayant
eu le concours pas plus que vous ne
verrez des semailles dans un article du
figaro
c'est aussi vrai pour la littérature
scientifique d'ailleurs maintenant que
tu dis c'est vrai que j'ai jamais vu je
crois de
des moggi dans des articles
scientifiques des articles de presse il
ya un endroit où les où les médias se
servent des emoji c'est sur les réseaux
sociaux donc ça c'est plutôt les
community managers ce qui s'en servent
et eux ils servent des emoji soit pour
donner du contexte aux articles qui
partage soit pour donner le thème
général tu vois peut-être dans certains
médias qui essaye de faire un peu jeunes
de casser les codes ils peuvent utiliser
des et moggi ou des mêmes dans leur
article
mais c'est hyper connoté donc tu verras
pas ça dans des magazines hyper sérieux
pour pour des gens d'un âge mûr et donc
c'est vraiment pour faire faire jeune
qua non pour que le web
et puis s'installer comme une norme dans
les médias ça a mis beaucoup de temps
pareil pour les vidéos là ça fait
quelques années que ça commence à
devenir un peu la norme dans les médias
pour un peu des moyens donc les emoji à
mon avis c'est pas pour tout de suite
quoi
ouais donc pas tout de suite que dans le
13 heures là on a on a une petite pêche
ou des petites gouttes quoi xd regardez
ce reportage en lozère en comparant le
smiley aux interjections géomines
différence de taille si vous pouvez
difficilement vous retenir de vocaliser
certains interjections dans le cadre
d'une conversation orale vous pouvez
choisir vos smiley quitte à ralentir le
rythme de la conversation à vous faire
genre que vous avez pas eu de message
pour bien faire mûrir votre choix
parce qu'on connaît les techniques vous
n'allez pas me la faire on peut donc
légitimement se poser cette question les
smileys sont-ils honnête et bat pas
vraiment pas tout à fait c'est compliqué
si les smileys ont contribué à
bouleverser la frontière entre l'écrit
et l'oral
ils ont aussi bouleversé la frontière
entre le contrôlable non contrôlable là
où vous enverriez une bonne partie de
signaux inconscient et spontanée à
l'oral vous pouvez les rationnaliser
lorsque vous utilisez une messagerie
instantanée et ainsi augmenter votre
marge de manoeuvre et smiley permettent
de contrôler l'image que l'on souhaite
renvoyer communiquer des émotions qui ne
sont pas celles que l'on a dans les
faits mais celle que l'on pense les
meilleurs dans tel ou tel cas vis-à-vis
de telle personne
la seule partie un contrôle à qui
demeure c'est l'interprétation de ces
smiley de la part de votre interlocuteur
cependant il n'est pas impossible que la
création d'habitude et la rapidité
d'utilisation des plateformes de
messagerie conduisent à une certaine
forme de spontanéité qui cependant ne
rivaliseront jamais avec celle de l'oral
il est possible aussi que l habitude des
pratiques au sein d'un même groupe
social puisse y conduire
désormais le smiley s'est bien imposé
dans notre société existe désormais une
table unicode réservé aux smiley
certains d'entre eux sont donc
informatiquement parlant strictement
équivalent à n'importe quel caractère
que ce soit la lettre r le point virgule
ou même le chiffre 4 désormais la
plupart des applications qui servent de
messagerie instantanée comme instagram
twitter ou facebook utilise peu ou prou
les mêmes desseins et comme c'est le cas
pour les mots certains ont évolué en
usage et encensent en fait c'est même
lusage qui dictent strictement tout il
n'existe aucune norme préexistantes à
leur signification
c'est le cas de l'aubergine par exemple
qui désigne désormais le pénis ce
détournement sémantique ne fut pas au
bout d'instagram d'ailleurs qui avait
bloqué le pauvre légumes dans ses
recherches une levée de boucliers avait
eu lieu sur twitter avec le hashtag
freezing plane ce un moyen pour quelques
enseignes de grande distribution de
gratter un peu de visibilité au passage
il ya quelques mois facebook et aller
dans la même direction en proscrivant
dans certains cas usage des émoticônes à
caractère sexuel à savoir l'aubergine la
pêche et les gouttes d'eau le pénis la
vulve et l'éjaculât si vous avez besoin
d'une traduction facebook motive ce
choix par son besoin de lutter contre la
prostitution sur le réseau social et
contre le contenu qui facilite
encouragent ou coordonne les rencontres
sexuelles entre adultes
ce qui est fascinant c'est que ces
symboles s'imposent comme des
idéogrammes compris et partagé par des
gens parlant plusieurs langues
différentes
on peut convertir des mots en symbole
sans passer par l'écriture alphabétique
on peut donc contourné la barrière de la
langue je n'ai pas besoin de comprendre
le tchèque si jamais je vois dans un
tweet aubergines gouttes d'eau au milieu
d'un texte donc pénis éjaculats si vous
n'avez pas suivi
ça marche avec d'autres émoticônes 1
c'était juste là parce qu'on était dans
le thème notons cependant que parfois la
signification d'un émoticônes et
cloisonnée un espace culturel lorsque la
l'impensé en l'air est apparu tout le
monde dans le monde occidental il ya vu
un symbole italien et c'était sa
fonction dédiée d'ailleurs et en inde ce
geste serre a demandé si quelqu'un a
faim dans le monde arabe il sert a
appelé au calme et dans certaines
communautés bdsm il sert c'est un geste
pour le fist fucking alors monté je t'ai
fait une petite présent sur les i moggi
dans la marketing dans la pub tout ça
c'était obligé
en fait en gros pour moi l'utilisation
des moggi dans la com elle tient pour
plusieurs raisons tu vois déjà ça
intéresse beaucoup les marques et tout
ce qui concerne comment on va impacter
le consommateur et comment est ce qu'on
va faire en sorte qu'il mémorise le truc
est clairement badé emoji c'est hyper
visuel et donc forcément ça marche
toujours mieux qu'un discours ou du
texte pour impacter visuellement ou en
plus faire en sorte que la personne va
retenir la formation à côté de ça ça
crée aussi façade comme on l'a dit tu
vois ça transmettre des émotions
donc forcément qui dit émotions dix
engagements et ça c'est un truc qui va
chercher par les marques maintenant
c'est d'associer des émotions à leurs
produits et du coup forcément bas en
mettant des hémorragies dans ta comme un
tas de styles et des émotions et
forcément tu augmentes l'engagement des
consommateurs envers la marque et ce qui
est cool aussi
c'est que toutes ces émotions et tout ce
qu'on veut communiquer autour d'un
produit au consommateur bain avec des
emoji en fait t'es universel tu peux te
redresser un peu à toutes les langues
donc en fait c'est super idéal pour
faire des campagnes internationales
d'accord je te donnerai je te donne un
indice sur 20 ha ouais bon je m'en vais
depuis les années 60 ou 70 ce serait
donc le début des smileys pourtant il ne
date pas vraiment non plus de ce moment
là pas du tout même si france soir est
souvent considéré comme le premier
journal en faire usage serait oublier ce
journal du 2 septembre 1893 de rhénanie
prussienne en allemagne ou encore dans
cette publicité du 10 mars 1953 du new
york tribus et s on pourrait aussi
parler de la signature de cet abbé en
1741 ou même de se basent itic du
premier millénaire avant notre ère eh
oui si vous pensiez que nos aïeux
étaient bien plus sérieux et les criques
nous autres leur pauvre descendance en
déshérence et bien vous vous trompez par
ailleurs des personnalités dont on
dirait volontiers que leur travail est
très sérieux s'ils sont intéressés c'est
le cas du philosophe ludwig wittgenstein
qui en parle dans ses cours à cambridge
en 1938 par les notes qui en sont tirées
pu publier on trouve trois semaines et
une réflexion générale sur leur
utilisation
bien avant l'ère d'internet finckenstein
considère que le smiley est bien plus
précis et flexi pour retranscrire une
émotion car simple adjectif aujourd'hui
le smiley est incontournable
décliné sous diverses sortes accompagné
d'autres et mogi ou émoticônes toujours
plus imagé ou précise dans le sens est
libre ou bien arbitres
r il a cassé le monopole du texte pur le
gif animé n'est que la continuité du
smiley si aujourd'hui nous avons
beaucoup de guides tirés de films de
vidéos youtube de programmes télé vidéo
culte du net en général cette
utilisation était très limité à l'époque
si ce n'est inexistante
tout simplement car nous n'avions pas
tous le débit nécessaire à leur
affichage moi j'ai eu internet gens en
2005 on voyait les charges et les images
en direct lors les vidéos allait se
lever de bonne heure ce format a
historiquement beaucoup servi pour
l'espagne les animés puisqu'il
permettait d'afficher des versions
animées très légère car composée de très
peu de couleurs sur msn ou sur les
chattes room
ils étaient légion bon si vous aussi
vous êtes nostalgique de cette belle
époque des années 2000 sobrie leslie
famine tout ça est bien n'hésitez pas à
venir en parler sur le petit score de du
vortex dont le lien est en descriptions
notamment vous pouvez cliquer commenté
partagé m la cloche il ya quoi d'autre
vous abonner
voilà c'est comme ça que j'aurais dû
répondre à leur style avec un gif
savamment à tout le monde comprend c'est
moins figuratifs et sérieux tu viens
moyens j'ai vu d'enterrement ça vous
dérange pas on pourrait l'intérêt pour
de vrai ce coup là on vote non non on
vote panon s'inquiète pas valentine on
va essayer de bien s'en occuper pour
passer à autre chose et c'est comme ça
et pas autrement
je compte pas chez le fleuriste aussi
[Musique]
bon on vous a déjà expliqué la vidéo
d'avant et la [ __ ] ou encore d'avant
donc
donc on va remettre une couche mais
actuellement en direct sur twitter sur
ma chaîne vous pouvez venir parler du
sujet
si vous voulez si vous voulez pas venir
en parler vous pouvez venir écouter un
son choix de pains et puis il ya déjà
pas mal quoi voilà qu'on nous vient des
biens des vient dé tous et on vous
attends quoi maintenant